this week on world stories China The
Silence of the bees
Togo a health system on life support but
first to the Islamic Republic of Iran
where women often faced exclusion from
participating in sporting events but
that hasn't stopped this team of female
weight lifters from pushing their way to
the top it's training time in this gym
and Western Tehran where champions have
pumped iron foot decades the weights are
just as heavy as they look yet for
Anna's and the other girls lifting them
is a dream come true my dad was a
weightlifter I've loved the sport ever
since I was a child and I watched every
competition so as soon as it was
possible I started lifting weights
myself a shoe corner and as is proud to
continue the family tradition and her
passion has paid off she's the strongest
of the four girl team so far the brains
behind the girl success has his office
just one floor higher Ali Moradi is
president of Iran's weightlifting
Association and perhaps the Gulf's
biggest fan he says there shouldn't be a
difference between men and women in his
sport
we have many Iranian men who have many
championship titles and our record
holders in the field of weightlifting
the World's Strongest Man right now is
an Iranian we want to achieve the same
with our women we hope that in the
future are not the far future I'm
talking about the Olympics of 2024 that
the Iranian women can add to these
glories to make that happen the girls
work hard every day just like the men
they live in the compound of the
Association and a close supervision by
doctors and coaches in just a few months
they have come a long way but it's far
from over
they don't have any experience yet next
year they'll do very well in
competitions for sure but for now we
just want them to build up confidence
but I am son after all
this is their first international
competition I meant everything I said
was ruled out every time you know I'm
hired to be a junior and as and the
others are excited to leave tear on for
a speak is done it's a historic first
for the girls and for Iran's female
weight lifters all together what men can
do women can do too
in the first five or six months since we
started weightlifting we've already
broken more than half of the women's
weightlifting records that's glorious
glory they plan to continue at this
week's tournament and beyond confident
well-prepared and determined to show the
world how strong Iranian women can be
[Music]
Global bee populations are on the
decline and China is especially affected
many believe it's due to the widespread
use of pesticides DW went to find out
how fruit growers are coming up with new
ways to pollinate their trees when the
cherry blossoms are out it's time for
watching yo to start work on something
that's normally taken care of by nature
the farmer pollinates her trees by hand
it should be bees doing this work but
here in the honey one region of
Southwest China there simply aren't
enough of the beneficial insects to go
around our yields were simply too low
the trees were flowering well but only
produced a few fruits even then we heard
about hand pollination we checked it out
and then started doing it ourselves hand
pollination is a painstaking task first
farmers have to find flowers which have
only just opened the pollen dust has to
be fresh and clean and removed very
carefully wool and her husband Zhang
Zhang Jia pollinate each tree three
times nowadays it's really hard work
being a fruit grower we have to spend a
lot of time tending our trees cause they
Global bee populations are on the
decline and China is especially badly
affected most regions no longer have any
native varieties the main problem is the
widespread use of chemicals in the
district capital shang-chi farmers come
to jungyeon malls store to stock up on
fertilizers herbicides and insecticides
we tell farmers not to spray during the
flowering period because then the bees
won't go on the blossoms at all other
times though the farmers happily spray
away on average Chinese farmers use
twice as many pesticides as their
European counterparts meanwhile
beekeeping has become a profitable
business here
Huang Bo Eun leases his bees to local
farmers on a daily basis he charges five
euros per hive per day ling gufu when
farmers pollinate by hand they only
roughly distribute the pollen on the
blossoms bees go right into the center
of the flower and take the pollen
exactly where it needs to go
it sounds like easy cash but huang bo
Yuans these need a lot of attention
they'll start spraying the apple trees
so I pack up my bees and take them to
the forest otherwise they'll die
watching yo and her husband though don't
want to spend money on renting bees so
instead for the next three weeks they'll
be in their orchard pollinating their
trees by hand
making migrants or refugees undergo
medical tests to determine their actual
age has become a topic of heated debate
in Germany their concerns older asylum
seekers are just claiming to be minors
to improve their chances of staying in
the country
how old is this refugee is he an adult
or still a minor since fleeing
Afghanistan Hoffman tomorry has already
learned that his age plays an enormous
role in Germany the traffickers told us
refugees if you are 20 or 21 then make
yourselves younger because it will be to
your advantage then they cannot deport
you German officials check the age of
refugees if there are doubts about
whether there are legal minors there's a
psychological interview and a medical
exam x-rays are wrist bones of teeth or
CT scans of the collarbone but critics
say bone tests cannot precisely
determine a person's age you cannot
always determine a person's exact
chronological age based in the age of
his or her bones there's a range that
can span one to three years
one to three years
can make a huge difference under 18
year-olds are assigned a guardian help
in the asylum process and accommodation
with the youth welfare service for
Refugees aged 18 and above the initial
conditions in shared accommodation are
often much worse many must rely on their
own devices
Ahmed tomorry has never lied about his
age he's 24 has received political
asylum and is in a training program but
he knows many others who are pretending
to be younger hoping it will help them
access help education and prevent them
from being deported
hospital workers in Togo have been
striking for better equipment and more
staff the public sector in this West
African country is completely
underfunded DW got a look at what that
means in one of the country's largest
hospitals
this child was diagnosed with malaria
but his high fever won't go away he's
been in the hospital for two weeks and
now his mother has run out of money for
medicine I don't have the funds I went
to a private clinic but I soon run out
of money and we had to leave without
money they can't do anything that's what
they tell you the only way I can buy
medicine as if someone gives me money as
a gift donate so far I haven't eaten
anything since this morning
addict whose son Rafael needs to see a
specialist but the staff at Togo's
biggest Hospital is on strike only
emergency treatment is available David
Doce is one of the strike leaders and
has already been arrested twice as a
result the doctor says he has no choice
he refuses to support a health care
policy that he says is deplorable
because I won't appear amici we've been
trained in a profession that's meant to
cure people of disease but at the moment
we can save any lives we company don't
curse it's difficult suppose we are on
strike to change the situation which is
very bad like we don't have enough staff
or enough equipment he didn't have most
of the equipment and the state-run
hospitals is antiquated according to the
communication minister a commission has
been appointed to deal with the
healthcare crisis
whose SPO who commits we hope we can
bring in all sides together on this
issue but now you see the government has
to take the overall economic situation
into consideration let's keep it that
pure is a fool and then decide which
problems to address first to the sweet
Moya
you know Thelma that's something dr.
David Doce says he's heard all too often
no le Clerc some it's clear that this is
a government strategy to delay the
process la communication what it
communicates doesn't reflect reality
that's a shame cinema you get the
impression that the government has
different priorities than the concrete
problems of the population that's why
dr. Dorsey and many of his colleagues
say they have no other option than to
earn their living in private clinics
instead of the state-run hospitals and
it's those very clinics that offer
treatment that's unaffordable to most
togolese including elessedil ku and her
son Rafael
[Music]